hey gang let's talk about that middle
class famous tour baby
getting bigger and better and it just
keeps her rolling on it's a live
stand-up comedy show plus we played a
little lyg with the crowd as I always
say great way to introduce new people to
the show so grab the squad and come out
and see us yeah guys in October we're
going to be in Nashville and then we're
headed up there to Indy then November
we're hitting Atlanta two shows added
there then we're headed to Charlotte we
got Philly Two Sold Out shows there I
apologize you snooze you lose then
December we're hitting Providence and
Boston those are currently sold out but
we're adding new shows stay tuned
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash now
here are your hosts Kevin Ryan and H
Foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's favorite new podcast this
is are you garbage little show we sit
down with your favorite comedians and we
find out the group to be classy uh-huh
just a big old piece of trash I'm your
host Dave trolley coming at you on a
beautiful day we're down here at
antody's basement you know she's
upstairs she's got the meatballs going
she's got manicotti she's got fresh
garlic bread because her namesake her
baby boy is in the building ladies and
gentlemen the only biological relative
the bloodline lives off Brian [ __ ]
six
that is that's insane wow
take that over there in England I'll
tell you that right now we got our own
royal family in the house my co-host is
coming at you from right next to me he's
the CEO of Ru garbage she's an
international businessman he's the
prince of Park Avenue but always no
matter what time of the year it is King
of the boardwalk baby look at him give
it up for KJ Kevin James Ryan Hey gang
thanks for tuning in as always please
make sure you're right where you
subscribe on iTunes full video available
on YouTube as of those as you know those
numbers are cooking Michael T-Bone and
then uh obviously the greatest website
of all time
www.patreon.com are you garbage check it
the [ __ ] out gang Sweet Lord do us a
favor gang and he doesn't have a mic
this week because we've got a couple
special guests in the house but how
about a nice round of applause put down
what you have in front of your cup of
coffee champagne whatever you're
drinking and give it up for the one the
only T-Bone McMuffin Toby McDonald
we love you pal
piece of [ __ ] cut that T-Bone's got no
mic because he's got two of them we got
two of the funniest dude the biggest
dirt
man we show up we try to be nice
the host oh you [ __ ] the podcast do me a
favor give it up for Mr Ryan Shaner and
Mr Brian six hey guys how's it going two
old Pals of ours which I just realized
how crazy six was getting a really good
look at him in the light
yeah I don't know why the glass is
something I really took it all in this
is just off to a crazy part getting a
look at you being eclipsed by your face
Jesus Christ
sorry I couldn't see you on the Dark
Side of the Moon
[Laughter]
boys how the hell are you we're good how
you doing we're doing good how was it
trip pop
shitty we got the lake God damn delayed
so many [ __ ] times yeah so I don't
need any Guff
I might take a delayed train to get my
balls broke yeah
let's get into whacking up this whole
[ __ ] merch money here
I heard how they described Twitter for
The Listener for The Listener uh aunt
tutty is actually Brian six's real hand
tutty yes that came from we asked one of
the questions we ask is do you have any
aunts or uncles that don't go by their
first name like I have an ansupi and an
ankwini and he goes oh yeah
and lived on and it was too perfect and
we I called you and asked you do you
mind if we do the the podcast down at
Tony's basement yes you asked her she
said it was okay and that's how we got
down here you took insane creative
Liberty with her and made her Guinea as
[ __ ] yeah she's from Ireland she's
making me an Italian part of Ireland
yeah yeah
the loudest part of the MRI
she's from the boot
if she what side of your family is
Italian though my dad's your dad's side
so that's where when you guys are down
the shore oh yeah and you do the family
reunion at the zoo oh that was it you do
your family yeah
he don't buy a lion there yeah was he
standing out there I got into the game
don't tell anybody how big was the
bathroom Kevin Jesus Christ
I imagine not that great to be honest
with you no way there's uh I I know
Lion's dicks are kind of like dog dicks
they come out yeah it's so good the only
one that's really solid is the whole
actually he's like no I have scientific
information then I'm just saying uh
horses are they oh man they're real ones
yeah those guys elephants too really
yeah elephant dicks are gigantic yeah
it's like this Honda yeah whales yeah
but they probably look weird they do
look weird do you know that uh the
[ __ ] uh picture of a Loch Ness
monster that's been used for years the
black and white one that looks like a
shadow it's a whale's dick could you
imagine how long someone's been like is
that really true yeah dude there's no
way it's definitely [ __ ] true look it
up T-Bone can you get on that that is
whale dick just Google whale dick it's
so that when uh I think are there whales
in the lock I guess so that sponsor was
not a whale screen I'm telling you it is
bring up the picture [ __ ]
you gotta go nine subreddits I'm telling
you I did not go on [ __ ] PornHub and
not see a whale's dick that's my boys on
Fortune that's what I get all my crypto
shots all my crypto and whale dick
information I knew about Bigfoot's [ __ ]
on PornHub as well do you have anybody
in either one of your families that
would believe in something like a
Bigfoot okay or because you hear you
come from like kind of country folks
yeah dude I knew a couple my uncle John
said he saw a skunk ape on the [ __ ]
Appalachian is that Bigfoot yeah it's
the same thing
a swamp ape and Florida Bigfoot ain't
like creature said to inhabit the
forests and swamps of some Southern
United States notably in Florida they
kick really bad though they smell really
bad
they kick that's why they call it smell
they can't get the rumor oh yeah that's
why they call it the skunk ape I didn't
know because it stink because they throw
it at you it's getting out [ __ ] balls
on their [ __ ] and shoot it out
everywhere a couple of dingleberries
um any UFO sightings in your families
[ __ ] I wish
Ed I'll be bummed out if I die without
seeing a UFO for real they're taking you
straight up I would [ __ ] I would love
it I've been [ __ ] you you'd be probed
in no time dude I would hope that I
would just be taken away and then never
return for like I do that thing like uh
most of us would things are going good
the scratch off is just three saucers
you like pick me up get me the [ __ ] out
in your reality you get abducted by a
scratcher yeah
how was uh how was the summer for you
guys
donations down the shore not as much as
I want it uh I surprised my dad on
Father's Day that was good what'd you do
surprise jump down from the closet at
him yeah he called me an [ __ ] and
that was it
it's like what the hell are you doing
[ __ ] like all right wait you
surprised him down the shore yeah it was
my birthday too okay and then he called
me and then you went upstairs so that's
good wait so hold on it's Father's Day
yeah but your birthday is on Father's
Day next day oh that Monday so I came
down so my sister knew we surprised them
and your dad lives down the shore yeah
all the time though yeah your parents
together still yes all right so they got
a shore house yes I'm guessing Wildwood
do you have a warrant as well when are
they usually in bed
what door is usually unlocked holy [ __ ]
he likes his glasses
[Laughter]
six took two follow-up questions like no
I'm done with this it was like three
he's killing me
but yes they live full time down the
shore and I thought it'd be a funny
surprise a good surprise hey what's up
yeah they were coming in from the bar
and he's walking up the steps and then
when he opens the door I was in the
kitchen I was like surprise and he's
like what the [ __ ] ass like God damn it
yeah
Christ all right and then just went
upstairs and we hung out after you know
I have a follow-up question if you don't
mind go ahead this is on Father's Day
that you do this yeah but you didn't
show up until
in the wee hours of the night no it was
like five five six o'clock he was
getting in from day drinking oh yeah no
shower happy hour baby down the shore
dude come on you know where he's at
he's right across the harbor dude this
is Wildwood I assume where else we're
not allowed in this Seattle spots
[Laughter]
dude so [ __ ] hot and miserable and
stupid in Philadelphia I didn't go
anywhere the [ __ ] pea season was that
top peak what like in the streets you
mean oh the smell of pigs dude though
every like so there's only the Broad
Street in the market Frankfurt and now
the Broad Street oh the Subways has
become the new market Frankfurt and
there is just piss everywhere that's
tough and murders and murder oh yeah
murder all sorts so much murder it's so
good I got showed guns for the first
time not flash I've had guns pointed at
me a few times but shown them like that
was yourself
here I was waiting I was waiting I could
do it man I'll do it right
I'm the only one to play solo Russian
Roulette
you know how to do it man it's like why
are you wearing that red bandana it's
like I was having a good game day uh
wait so people showed you guns so I got
off uh I got off at uh the [ __ ] wait
a minute is this when your house tell
them where you got off of the [ __ ]
side I got off at uh Allegheny and Tioga
also known as Fallujah yeah it's a nice
nice area I actually wanted to help it
dude I saw him injecting heroin into his
elbow and I remember being like hey man
you're okay
come on that's a waste of a bag bro like
you're gonna break the needle
that's a [ __ ] elbow what are you
doing go for the vein bruh or the
eyeballs things like I knew it was sad
but I wanted to be like I just need to
help you get a hot shot and get out of
it
my head is just like dude if you can
just do one more and get the [ __ ] out of
here so I don't have to see you next
time get rubber gloves you're pulling it
out it's like a dirty I've become
[ __ ] Stoner Kevorkian right then who
are you house sitting for and where was
this person that you need a house sitter
so he who would hire you as a house this
dude first off I'm pretty good at house
sitting boys we're gonna have a lot of
questions so just so you know I'm just
telling you our our producer Danny he
was on vacation with his lady they went
to Galapagos the Galapagos Islands so
they let me be in charge his house and
his dog okay zero dogs I was dog sitting
but I stayed there house City makes it
seem like you were like an estate out in
the Hampton somewhere I mean you were in
you were in North Philly watching a dog
you were organizing the deliveries in
the in the kitchen staff
like Alfred yeah I had DuckTales on and
everything yeah
I was [ __ ] killing it but yeah I had
to I just watched this dog for uh four
days what kind of dog uh [ __ ] uh
Galapagos Island for four days they were
there actually they were there I don't
even know where it is well they were
only in the Galapagos before you go down
to the shore for four days okay they
went to they went to South America for
three then they went to the Galapagos
and then yeah that's still too short man
it's only a week dude it was it was a
good week for them yeah it's all right
me just hanging out with a dog I love it
is the name of the dog no the Goblin's
the name of the dog breed is spuds
how many dogs have you been bitten by in
your lifetime five yeah I would assume
it's been a bunch one was spudsman
my dad took me to just like yeah we're
gonna check out spots
don't go get near his face though that
was a certain time when Spud showed up
somewhere it was good it was a party
time I actually saw Spud shooting heroin
into his elbow I was like what are you
doing it's not gonna work it's hard to
became his Handler you gotta be all
right with this [ __ ] oh Jesus Christ
yeah it was just a very uh it was boring
boring summer for me I wish I did more
so what happened with the guns oh so I
was walking home from work so it's like
about 12 12 at night okay as I'm walking
this car pulls up alongside of me and I
have like one headphone in to pretend
like I'm listening in music and the
other one out so I hear someone's trying
to [ __ ] kill me sure so which you're
looking you're looking for trouble I'm
just walking are these wired earbuds or
Wireless these are wired okay I'm just
asking he's wearing the exact headphones
I'm wearing the camouflage for North
Philadelphia okay calm down so anyway
I'm walking and I see this car pull up
alongside of me and I don't acknowledge
it because I'm just like whatever and
it's slowing down and then getting in
front of me and slowing down again
getting in front of me and slowing down
again so that would have been [ __ ] I
like ran the other way no you don't run
it's like running from a dog that's how
you get bit you dumb [ __ ] what you do is
you jump in the car yeah yeah you join
the crew you try to carjack them dude
I do it finger guards like get the [ __ ]
out let me see your hands put it up to
my head
of the car I'm gonna kill myself in
front of you hey this guy's all right
let him in but I I stopped then I
stopped I was like what the [ __ ] is this
and it was like kids the oldest one had
to be like [ __ ] 16 or 17 and they
just show me these guns they got and
they have [ __ ] pistols and one has
like what looks like a [ __ ] rocket
launcher or something yeah dude and I'm
just like okay
what are you gonna do like I'm making
any demands nothing just showed me them
they just showed me that that's kind of
nice like yo check out these guns it was
like so bizarre I was like well all
right and then they sped up and then
like darted out of the [ __ ] scene you
could have became friends with those
kids I was hoping
they didn't say anything because I took
my earbud out I'm like are you guys
gonna like offer me to buy these because
what did you actually say give me the
exactly I didn't say anything I just
stood there because I was like what am I
going to say to these [ __ ] and then
what'd they say to you nothing they just
showed me the guns by hanging out the
window they showed you they just showed
me them and then they took off it was
bizarre it was the most bizarre
interaction I've ever had with anybody
oh they're probably looking for some
approval
it's a good look that's a good looking
AK-47 all right
you shoot your eye out with that love
you buddy huh get out of here thanks
mister
damn
all right but also let's touch on you
you mentioned briefly beforehand that
you're you're in you do some wrestling
on the side yeah every now
like you've gotta I don't I don't know
anybody that's ever say Roman Greco no
no no uh so it's a like a an amateur
professional okay are you involved in
this God no
he would never dude the day that he
would he would never support him are you
in his corner like Jimmy Hart with a
guitar
dude you got a snake in a bag he came
out full honky-tonk man that would be
[ __ ] sick these two are wild but I
know there was yeah no six has never
been there it's like asking your dad to
come anywhere it's like not gonna happen
no yeah so I the whole thing is I'm a
the Persona is I'm a veterinarian
I saw cause you were in Scrubs you were
in a very tiny ring in Scrubs scrubs so
I'm a veterinarian that only puts
animals down oh God so that's the whole
like personas I'm a bad guy who only
this is on TNT what channel
the last masters of the rock wasn't it
I told him to go home what's stone cold
really like
uh yeah it's okay do you bring prod you
bring the stuffed animal with you so the
whole thing is the first time I did like
a dead cat or something no I wish see
the whole thing is the guy the guy who
runs the show like he I what sucks is I
always have to run matches by him but
over the three years that I've been
doing it he's gotten more and more mad
at me for the [ __ ] I've done because
he's gotten hate mail for stuff because
you're you're a bit of a wild card I
would call it you showed a video of a
[ __ ] dog Golden Retriever getting
whacked by a car that was [ __ ] great
it was funny though no dogs live I don't
know if that dog left but it wasn't like
gory it was just a dog getting popped by
a [ __ ] you don't see it wait how is
there an audio visual aspect to this so
the whole coming in so it comes quite a
production thing yeah they got some they
got some little bells and whistles yeah
but uh yeah there's a screen and the
whole thing is the guy I wrestled he
came out and he was talking about how
like oh it sucks being on the road
because you had to put your dog in a
kennel and then I came out like yeah not
only do I run the kennel you're
wrestling for your life you're wrestling
for the life of your dog and if you lose
I'm gonna put the dog down via Skype
Jesus and then everyone starts booing as
you do and then we had the wrestling
match and then he won so you're a bad
guy always a heel you're not Mr America
way to put it together
and the last Pony crosses the finish
line here
you don't got any makeup at the house
what the [ __ ] nah dude a speedo or
something why don't you pick up video
games or something oh that's so funny
you're a crazy guy what's the name of
the character the vet
what'd you think it was fun Dr Hank
Johnson
it's just a real guy's name yeah you
should just book a local vet yeah and
just ruin his life too
[Music]
all his reviews Victor Leland it's like
no damn it I didn't do that
yeah the vet uh does whatever the [ __ ]
he wants oh now I know why you haven't
been there yeah
no I I wouldn't I wouldn't you wouldn't
want him there
I would have went but it's like it's
also you got to remember this is more of
like a an acting where it's like Shane
is the only one actually physically
going in hard for wrestling the other
[ __ ] is two [ __ ] trying to be funny
with their characters and that's it he's
the only one like going hard it's very
like Vaudeville and I want him to jump
off the top you guys been in Phil mocha
right in Philly anyway it's like a mini
I don't know it's a mini uh basically
venue but has a top
mezzanine yeah and we looked at I was
like you could jump off the top ECW
style and then the kid
go if Shane or stop being a [ __ ] and
right what is my second line here
meanwhile it's like it's two chicks like
playing [ __ ] no I want to get turned
back into the [ __ ] Bingo Hall in
South Philly he's new jacking it off the
mezzanine yeah I want him jumping off
the roof and I don't approve of the dog
videos I'm an animal lover yeah
put your life on the line lean those
kitties alone
Jesus Christ oh boys it sounds like you
had an interesting summer how long did
you stand on the show with your dad uh
that time it was only like three or four
times I only made it down like three or
four times total the whole summer it
sucks yeah I think I got down three
times yeah you drive down when you go
down no no usually oh Kyla will or I'll
take the train okay maybe hang on the AC
how was that place it was pretty nice
man I don't know much about casinos I
thought it was a pretty nice joint would
you play what slot machine
[Laughter]
I'm A Wheel of Fortune game I was like
what bathroom stall did you get caught
in it's like they gave me balloons every
time dragging me out
Jesus we did have a nice night we did
have a nice night everybody won a couple
of bucks everyone a couple everybody won
a couple of bucks it was pretty clean
I'll tell you what I can say this you
can tell the oxygen that's being
possible
I could really Talent at live it's my
[ __ ] Merit cigarettes that's no hard
but yeah I mean the oxygen beam you know
they pump oxygen into casinos yeah but
you know about the [ __ ] monster yeah
you know about the Loch Ness monster
look I only gamble with my life fully
Jesus Christ uh they pump in oxygen to
keep it because it makes you more alert
like heavier oxygen dude it's like I
could feel it yeah my first time I was
able to breathe right
in 15 years first time you had a full
lung capacity the only time it wasn't
snoring awake can I sleep here by the
way who does your CPAP machine here
get me out with that butcher box baby
put your box put your box who put your
butcher box we're getting sued
dude butcher boxes top shelf baby high
quality needles you can create for you
and your family when you get top Quality
Meat delivered to your door slide it in
the freezer when you're ready to use it
take it out before you go to work throw
it in the bowl in the sink come home
it's defrosted put the meal together
bang bang boom next thing you know
you're on the couch and you're chilling
watching a little ayj yeah I ain't
talking about no 2.2 Buck Chuck either
I'm talking about 100 grass-fed beef
free range organic chicken pork raised
crate free wild caught Seafood you
should see the wildlife you mainly raise
no antibiotics no hormones whatever you
need right to your door uh free shipping
and continental US no surprise fees you
can uh choose from a variety of box plan
options from curated to customize and
change your plan whenever you want I
like when they do it yeah let they know
what they're doing they know what they
know what the people like anyway that's
how I dictate what we're gonna make for
dinner yeah but we got in the freezer oh
yeah uh we've said it I said it once I
said it three million times I got a
whole butcher box freezer at my crib I
got everything I got the steaks I got
the seafood I got this I got it all baby
I'm blowing salmon
butcher box you hear that why don't you
straight man why don't you swim upstream
and straighten the big man out that yeah
Grizzly uh guys this is it where the
chicken meets the road why'd the chicken
cross the road there fatty look at his
butcher box say get to your refrigerator
I tell you how about your boxes offering
our listeners an incredible deal uh that
they've never offered before free
chicken for a year get out of here nuts
get two pounds of free chicken Kobe cut
this this is crazy you're gonna go on
there chicken breast for free in every
order when you sign up at butcherbox.com
ayg use code ayg claim this deal
butcherbox.com
ayg use code ayg do it gang support for
today's episode is brought to you by
true classic true classic which I would
like to call the greatest t-shirt
company that's all I wear you're finding
your [ __ ] getting on my board I'll be
honest with you they sent us a couple I
had them in here for a couple of days
all right I wasn't sure if they would
fit me I took them home I took one out I
put it on I don't think I'm ever wearing
any other t-shirts ever again I'm
telling you guys I know I seen you out
there at the meet and greets we got a
lot of bigger fellas feel great they
feel good they're cutting the shoulders
right they cut around they hide the
spare tire a little bit it makes you
look like a like a retired linebacker
yeah you feel all yoked up jacked up
yeah they're tight in the sleeves to
their grave here's the turkey it's a top
quality Comfort fitting t-shirt it's the
only one that I'm gonna wear moving
forward I'm telling you right now yes
guys uh they're giving uh are you
garbage listeners the hook up baby go to
trueclassic.com with code garbage uh
men's tees are designed to look good on
skinny models and that ain't us baby no
toe couple fat lard asses cooking around
here couple of wide lose oh yeah
um so here it is uh it's time you learn
to dress like a gentleman upgrade your
wardrobe with true classic get 25 off 25
percent off people are crazy holy [ __ ]
off trueclassic.com really he's giving
it away these days one more time get 25
off trueclassic.com with code garbage at
25 off and free shipping over a hundred
dollars with the code garbage at
trueclassic.com get yourself looking
like a doctor with true classic no it
was nice holy [ __ ] it was a good time
so what what game did you play we played
roulette yeah that's what we do we both
won we both won a couple bucks it was
nice spread it around a little bit I
give Kippy [ __ ] a lot especially how he
is in the casinos he gets real thing but
I've changed my course on we've fought
on this for years we went to a casino
one time together in Atlantic City like
two years ago after the show and he
[ __ ] stinks dude like he is not
you're getting more fun to be around
yeah you're you used to be a real tough
hang yeah we're all in general at the
casino in general okay but at the casino
for sure sure we're all there it's like
two in the morning we're at the casino
we're drinking we're have we're at all
at a table having a blast and he's like
let's get out of here man let's like we
had just got into the casino I didn't
get the life let's go over there and
smoke cigs and get a beer I'm like no
dude we're at a table we're playing it's
like six of us get free beard there too
I know and he does a really good job I
give him [ __ ] he does a really good job
of explaining the game to me very
patient he's a very good roulette so
this is like rain man just with two
retards that's what this is
[Laughter]
I don't know how to play cards I can
play uh I can play War that's okay I can
play that I don't know I don't know
anything about poker I don't know [ __ ]
about it anytime we've played before I
like just Bluff or what I think is
bluffing I'm like yeah that he pulls a
gun out on everybody he doesn't know
what he's doing I don't know
he's doing he's like I Bluff that one
I'm like that's not bluffing it's like
he's like all in his cards are upside
down
what the [ __ ] you doing there's a rules
card in there where did that come from
he's got the instructions I've got an
UNO reverse in there like here we go hey
you draw three Wild Card bang and I
raise you Colonel Mustard well that's
good though that's a basic game yeah
he's playing the inside yeah yeah I know
what you I know exactly what you're
talking about I dab it on the outside a
little bit too yeah that was kind of my
buffer if I knew if I knew I had a lot
of action on the inside I'd throw throw
a couple of chunks on the on on black or
on red yeah just a cushion they call
them chunks
he's putting Reese
I put three Skittles on black please sir
Ranch is not an option
I want to be paid out in shrimp
third of you walked away like what's
your Buffalo
head
the table's all greasy just slide just
slide it across
now we had a good dealer too yeah yeah
Philly's Jersey wait what casino are you
at we're live down
I met the other time oh oh the NAC we
were in Bailey's or Atlantic City and it
wasn't a good scene there was literally
there was literally a homeless there was
a homeless guy who was frosting at the
mouth stealing chips I'm sorry I wanted
to get out of there and go see if
Hooters was still open I love how that's
your folks you're like those are chips
or anybody's just grabbing chips I've
only brought his own Pringles there's a
barbecue they're not even ships off the
table but that's what I'm saying at the
one in Philly there wasn't a lot of that
I didn't get flim flamed when I went in
there
uh but you're also it's it's tough
because you know any characters when I'm
in there playing he's not subtle when
he's asking questions so it's like he
makes you look like you're also an idiot
you know what I mean yeah he's there and
he's like why are his colors different
than mine like he's getting all he gets
all speakers it's all flustered real
quick
you gotta be like that's a number four
he got a four so you're handling dude
what is it like when you go to
kindergarten with this [ __ ] guy at
the goddamn Casino
dude he won a bunch of he hit a number
for like a lot of like you know I don't
know yeah and he had like 20 bucks on
the number because he didn't no he just
like and just randomly hit it and then
they gave him like 900 or something damn
he's like but how much is this in real
money I thought it was a conversion
I know what he's talking about he's like
no but like in the real world if I went
to the store with this money how much is
it I'm like it's 900 dude it's like but
in American stuff
you can only use it at a duty-free shop
like I knew I could get traveling soon
he got a shitload of Kahlua in the car
you think it's a carnival you walk out
with 6 000 mustache Combs you're like I
know I had to spend this here hey check
it out it's a switchblade let's go this
is actually an in-sync poster in a frame
so you know it's good I'm doing pretty
good it's pretty good boys thank you for
coming in let's do some uh patreon cues
yeah guys as you know when you sign up
for the old patreon you get a question
right on the air and today we got the
boys from you [ __ ] the podcast to answer
your questions uh this one heir to the
throne Brian six yes some data will all
be yours I can't wait this is very this
is Eerie the painting is [ __ ] Eerie
yeah it's strange if you had more red
carpet in here we'd be out to what he's
living with me we are at Tony yeah red
carpet is the [ __ ] right carpet that
was cool for like one weekend I'm
talking about the red carpet that's not
coming off the ground that's embedded
into that house yeah yeah it almost
looks like a red asphalt yeah it's bad
it's like it's like the carpet at a
roller skating rink
it's so matted down here it's like all
purpose yeah I think that carpet was
called rug Bird that's just what that
was that's what they call indoor outdoor
carpet
um all right this one's from Devin what
is the worst place you've taken a dump
at
he said mine was a porta potty at a
music festival in Denver
in Dover Delaware at any porta potty is
going to be tough yeah you gotta bust a
hover in a porta potty and that's quick
can't do a hover oh Shana what do you
got I know I mean the worst place I've
ever taken [ __ ] was a way after so is
that Maple Grove Raceway
about a racetrack in a race car
[Laughter]
it wasn't actually it was I took a [ __ ]
in one of the the [ __ ] uh porta
potties But like after I left it wasn't
my [ __ ] it was my best friend Sean I
left and then I came back and he's
cracking up he's like you will not
believe the [ __ ] I just took in there
you have to go look at it and he's like
you'll know what [ __ ] is mine which
means that there was more [ __ ] in there
that I would have to separate and when I
went in there was a [ __ ] ant hill on
the back of this goddamn tank oh
on the back of it dude coming out of the
[ __ ] people were just [ __ ] on top of
other people's [ __ ] like a Mount Everest
of [ __ ] crap and his [ __ ] coil was
right on the top of it
it was the worst [ __ ] I've ever seen in
my life some esteemed colleagues I said
I know go check out my [ __ ]
no there's no way you wouldn't go look
at a boy's [ __ ] yeah for sure especially
if it was something of that nature I
totally yeah don't act like you don't
I'm not doing it on a Tuesday
yeah you met a friend I get but it
sounds like a little boy's [ __ ] sound
like Fast Eddie over there yeah you want
to look at a boy's [ __ ] would you
that's another table game in Atlantic
City come look at this 200 on that
foliage and guess the age of the thumb
get a good sniff on that I was gonna say
the woods I was Landscaping one time and
I was too scared that I really had to go
and my boy was one of those situations
where the guy that owns the Landscaping
Company would take you somewhere leave
you there and then go do a couple other
jobs while you're like weeding or raking
up something or doing something I really
had to go and I was too scared to knock
on the door so I just went into the
woods and and went to the Cool Hand Luke
yeah she's like taking it off what's
your wife with drop that off no no way
come on that was a bad situation you got
away with a sock or some [ __ ] yeah you
got to sacrifice the song my boots on so
what they don't come off yeah you cut
your underwear off and you take you wipe
your ass with it yeah I didn't have a
switchblade are you a landscaper you
didn't have any type of [ __ ] tool
whatever I can take a weed whacker to
myself
sorry yeah I just spread my cheeks and
really tried to make the best of it it
was all I was almost done work I just
couldn't wait that should be the time
yeah I was gonna say yeah maybe your
autobiography just spread my cheeks and
try to make the best of it
ain't too far off that's pretty good
mine was the oh sorry no I was gonna say
literally as I was doing it
the owner of the house and my boss had
come to look at the work that I had done
and they literally looked in the bed
looked in the woods and I was like 20
feet back
pulling your pants up I thought it was a
skunk ape the whale's penis out there
it's just you walking away out of focus
your cheeks there he goes
oh good lord mine was the day after my
21st birthday in North Wildwood at the
uh they have like a lifeguard stand like
you know there's like a beach Patrol
that has public bathrooms I mean the
bathrooms are from like the 60s those
are usually pretty sweet though those
like those like uh those Beach Patrol
like little houses yeah it was like a
garage for the most part with like a
public bathroom and
I was just like because I was like
hungry it was like hungover [ __ ] oh
shits man and it was like a hundred it
was like the middle of August so it's
like 100 degrees in there yeah and I was
oh I'd already been in the water so I'm
Sandy I'm wet I'm just sweating I just
remember me and I'm like this is the
lowest why'd you go to the beach why'd
you stay home get on the water baby 21st
birthday man I would have [ __ ] in the
ocean I was surfing yeah you can't [ __ ]
in the ocean six have you no I know
dudes who have though they told me they
did for sure in the ocean yeah yeah [ __ ]
in the ocean I was living there at the
time
oh you looked familiar I thought you
look familiar I have [ __ ] in the ocean
you ever [ __ ] in the ocean no
like on a public beach you just walk out
and go to the bathroom I pee all the
time like my family and we're like yeah
we're like I'm gonna run to the bathroom
just yeah you go in the ocean yeah yeah
there's like four Dudes walking in the
wall so you're saying all staying 20
feet apart and pee it's down the shore
it's a summer day the beach is crowded
no no no no I have never [ __ ] while
there's been people around I've been
night swimming on like the Outer Banks
and I'm going to the ocean drunk and I
just [ __ ] in the ocean I'll give you
that that's all right yeah you've been
night swimming in the ocean before hey
oh that's crazy why all he doesn't like
the ocean at all what is wrong with you
do you think it's haunted after dark
you went in the ocean this night no
those sharks are gonna get you old man
McIntyre owns that ocean don't go in
there
that's pretty good mine was at a
Philly's playoff game at the vet oh hell
yeah dude I was like nine years
the worst poop of your life was at nine
that's a tough one well the worst hits
the ship was I think that's what scarred
me with public bathrooms but I remember
just even when I was younger and small
the Gap at the vet I don't remember
there being I thought they took the
doors off at a certain point yeah the
crowd did [ __ ] get hammered ripping
them off
hanging off of one but the one I was in
I'm telling you you just walked by like
and I'm like all right yeah enjoy the
show you're like dangling off the
[ __ ] Bowl oh yeah just kicking oh
yeah what are you doing
okay take a look at him you want to see
a seventh inning stretch and check this
boy take a peek yeah the vet was rough
yeah
shout out to Dollar dog night though
that's too shabby we always say it
um all right this one's from Chris
anyone in your family have flame tattoos
[Laughter]
damn I literally was like yeah I was
like six for sure
idiot nobody's got Flames yeah I got a
[ __ ] Uncle an uncle yes I knew it
that's where you gotta get though yeah
yeah makes you punch harder
oh you know
dude anytime you see a dude in Flames
yeah you want to catch on the heat
God they're late they're not even
colored they're [ __ ] black
looks like somebody [ __ ] up it looks
like waves
and he ran out of money halfway oh you
also got him in like the 80s so they're
already [ __ ] um you know all faded
and [ __ ] oh that's so great did he have
a meaning behind him
uh no you just had a Trans Am in the 80s
that's in order to get it inspected yeah
him and my other uncle had matching
drinks well you're all set here the only
thing we need to see is uh your
registration and uh your flamethas on
your forearms and uh the cop comes up
he's just like yeah let me go just let
me out of here get pulled over you got
any flame tattoos in there son
that's good any other really bad tattoos
I don't think anybody you have tattoo
six none none no his father's my dad got
the worst that my dad had the worst
tattoos I've ever yeah I think it almost
deterred me from getting you don't have
any I have no time that's crazy
everyone's everyone always thinks he
does yeah everyone I'm surprised you
don't have one or two either I sat in
the chair twice I was like man [ __ ] it
that's always that's my dad used to say
that that's such a dirt bike I've been
in the chair two times I walked away
from it and the crazy thing here was
henna
I was like how long a week six months
he's like I can't be Wildwood's nuts all
right no my dad had uh he had two and
over his uh his right pack he had a an
eagles head the size of a quarter that
looked like somebody like had a stroke
while doing it was one of the worst
[ __ ] depictions of a bird I've ever
seen and then over top of his left Peck
was my mom's name written in Old English
with two asterisks that look like stars
on the side of her I know I know exactly
what you're talking about they were the
worst [ __ ] tattoos I'd ever seen and
part of me thought after my dad had died
I was I would get both of them to honor
my that's a lot of fun my mother and my
father in one day I told you I'll get
the [ __ ] [ __ ] Eagles head and I
want it just as bad yeah I don't want a
good one and I want Susan on my [ __ ]
other in Old English in Old English and
just the shittiest Old English I've ever
seen my grandfather's got a bunch but
he's got one of his forearm of a lady
sailor with a mustache well that's
pretty sick that's old school yeah
that's cool why does she have a mustache
though she's winking at you I don't [ __ ]
or something like that to get them yeah
he wasn't on Tugboat duty but he was in
the Navy yeah
not many Tugboat captains in our family
thank God Admiral tug damn dude and then
there was a lot of uh Tasmanian Devil
down that was big in the 90s
and the Notre Dame guy
I almost had the Fighting Irish guy
anything Looney Tunes whether it's on
your body whether it's clothing of the
spare tire on a Jeep Wrangler
yeah somebody always back off with the
guns like yeah Tad's got flap time
though you'll see it sometimes yeah he
was always big airbrushed on the uh on
the
spare tire oh yeah yeah such a [ __ ]
bad look man it is awesome
look he's like I don't know maybe
getting a good airbrush another [ __ ]
artist down there dude airbrushing yeah
right now
dude I was just I was just down in
Wildwood and the t-shirts down there
classic that one that they're selling
insane but the ones that their people
are wearing are even [ __ ] crazier
off color these things are in black and
white Daddio that is bad because I was
just like Jesus Christ
is still like the not only am I perfect
I'm Puerto Rican too A lot of that I
mean that's even Pro though the one was
like
um
uh two margaritas 18 three shots of
vodka you know nineteen dollars 14 beers
whatever going on with the girl that
drank all that Priceless damn dude
getting away with it Priceless that's
great
there are guys walking with a girl I'm
like this is crazy there's also bananas
that it's like it's like going back in
time but ones that don't make any sense
they have like uh like Marilyn Monroe
with face tattoos on it oh yeah but then
there's like one underneath it says
faces can't get pregnant or something
like that it's just something so rich
also a lot of booty shorts that say it's
not gonna slap itself yeah oh yeah yeah
real classy stuff they got going on down
there man it's crazy dude it's another
world down there it truly is but it's a
lot of it has never hasn't changed in my
lifetime and I guarantee it well it's
not they still do the fake Oakley brand
that says Wildwood but it's written in
Oakley Fox oh yeah yeah
my aunt got me a windbreaker one time I
was wearing it
no they're made out of like burlap
oh no they sell them yeah they're like
drug rugs yeah yes yeah yeah
the stripes on yeah
soda loves them he has one yeah you rock
those still soda
he was he was wearing it really party
time I used to sell that I worked at a
hippie boutique store called the habitat
what do they call what are they exactly
called they're they're like they have a
name stalls or ponchos yeah they're
Mexican ponchos yeah it's like it's a
Mexican or like you know Southwest
American type uh jonski they have like a
little v-neck yeah there's two strings
so it looks like a drug rug yeah but
that's the universal don't make the hood
tighter they're just they're just
decorations yeah it's weird so [ __ ]
stupid
um
that's perfect because this is uh this
one's from Chris ever just tucked the
front of your shirt in oh that was fun
out there with the front tuck going damn
dude fresh white nice pair of 18 shorts
too let me finish that sentence damn
dude
I don't know why I delayed that brush
whites no but you've uh yeah the T-shirt
behind the Buckle yeah I remember that
damn that was that was a hard look no
okay we're probably older when that hit
no I didn't do that I would only do that
at a necessity
it's what would be like different what
what like at a wedding or something like
that if I had a sport coat on and I
could get away with not tucking in the
back because every time I would sit down
it would come up anyway so I just tuck
it in the front and just kind of like
Bunch it up in the back you're a
different kind of fat guy
never for style I would never talk
anything in maybe that's the
autobiography title never for Style
oh really you look like a trendsetter uh
somebody said we should both do a
patreon episode in turtlenecks because
we're so against it dude that's a new
look dude that's a new look I've been
noticing especially at weddings where
they come in and it's uh man they come
in with a suit jacket with the
turtleneck and a chain over there
if you can pull it off you look yeah
like Pope could do it Tommy has a he
could do that he could do it I might be
able to pull it off you couldn't even
put it on it really wouldn't come off
you think I turned back with a fan on me
yes it'd be all stretched out probably
rolled down turtlenecks I just did it
last week not turtleneck but same like
uh turtleneck material okay uh how'd it
feel no collar it was all right I
haven't worn it what about a half neck
it's like I have like the 80s what's a
half turtleneck yeah like Uncle Eddie
Tommy's wedding there you go yeah get a
nice gold chain
okay I mean what do you want bookmaker
all of a sudden what the [ __ ] I just get
a regular nice gold chain yeah
all of a sudden
I got a guy I got a spool guy wow you
just pull it off yeah cut it don't wear
it for more than an hour though it will
affect you
she's got green rings around your neck
like check that out I remember the first
time I I discovered that that happens I
bought uh some I took some girl to Great
Adventure and I bought her a ring and
put her I thought she was the one huh
Jesus Christ
girl you're my seventh flag whoa whoa
what you got her a ring yeah
anybody barfed on her yeah I threw up on
her I'm not exactly on her but I threw
up I feel like a Gravitron or something
like that yeah because we hit like the
uh funnel cake and all that stuff very
heavy when you say
you did also I love when you're trying
to impress this girl and you go heavy on
funnel cake and then get on a ride that
spins you around it was so funny yeah
really trying to impress her huh I was
like 14 or 15 or something like that we
were there with like a couple other
couples
oh yeah and like my I think one of our
parents dropped us off
and dude how hard did you walk into that
[ __ ] Six Flags
ready to go yeah dude I knew it up with
her yeah ready to go you're like I'm
gonna show her how much fried dough I
can eat
what'd the ring look like I'm gonna show
her it was Tiffany what do you think it
looked like I don't know it was uh gold
with like
it might have had like some blue like
Stone on it or something like that that
I think fell out on the way home yeah
that was a Bud Light camera
what color was the egg you got it out of
what riddle did you get from the chicken
yeah and I remember she like had it on
she had it on like into the in like like
later on the night and she took it I was
like oh my God my finger because none of
us had ever seen that before I thought
that was a wives tale
no that's real that's real as [ __ ]
that's funny that you did you think you
were gonna last with her
I thought that was it man what's she
doing now
she works at Great Adventure which is
really weird
I have no idea she's the old man
she's actually a burn victim after that
night yeah he's talking about YouTube
with the glasses what does the dance
moves right yeah that's all right it's
like damn what happened to her a lot
um all right this one's from Tim first
time 10 homie ever own a pair of zubas
oh God did you really [ __ ] you I didn't
even know where you could to me that was
like you would see them they came with a
sports illustrator subscription they
have a [ __ ] good that starter
pullover Eagles looked with a pair of
zooms
only Eagles I'd assume obviously the
Dolphins ones were pretty sweet though
when the new Falcons came out man
Eagles and I had uh the Raiders be too
young for that that was I was super
young that was for older kids when I was
a kid my uncle with the Flames he still
wears awesome all right dude an uncle
with flames
I swear to God I wore them all the time
yeah you said these are shorts I was
like they're cut off look how uneven
yeah yeah dude cut off zubas is a hard
fight yeah there's still Eagles out that
you don't go Birds obviously
that's the only excuse like still birds
out yeah that's the only reason I'm
gonna let it slides because we're
tailgating right now and we won you look
like [ __ ] but them are [ __ ] those
colors don't run man yeah we're at any
restaurant in Philly yeah
I walk into any Applebee's I'm known I'm
known here damn he still rocks them huh
uh yeah I bet they're probably he might
not still but they've definitely passed
the time he should have been rocking
them I'm pretty sure he probably has
them still dude if you have them you
should frame them you should frame them
and put them behind them people want
like a Jersey
you know I don't know that I know this
[ __ ] are you garbage money man you
know we met last week Mike yeah
dude he was awesome
wait do you know him
I think we all know just because he did
just because he didn't really play that
well you're so mad at him are you
kidding me he was the most sold [ __ ]
everyone was wearing his jerseys
one of the worst picks ever it was our
first round pick what's he doing [ __ ]
busting tables not to stand nah he kills
it man dude looks really good yeah I
think real estate or something like that
yeah he's probably a good guy
what's he been up to
that's [ __ ] great uh this one's from
Jared uh is it garbage to fold your
socks down so they look like ankle socks
come on that's [ __ ] sick
well listen this is I would go there was
two ways you could do it you could roll
it down you know what I mean like or
under the heel or take the front and
fold what did you do I went front and
folded on top yeah no I went up because
it gave the tongue some life you know
what I mean oh I always went under so I
was stepping on it no I've done that
before it's the same difference depends
on the sock too if you tie your shoes
tighter it doesn't move either yeah true
true wait so you go below the ankle what
do you mean you were stepping on it so
like you hang let it like say this is
your foot and the slack you pull it down
to where you'd want it on the ankle and
then tuck it under oh and I would still
stand on it you never did that no I
wouldn't feel I wouldn't want to uh my
feet on the onions I know what you're
talking about it's like you're walking
on the ends of your socks
in the 90s they cost like 70 million
dollars
one pair oh my god dude there was time I
remember I would be putting them on like
damn I'm gonna want to wear these
tomorrow too I started stealing them
from my mom my mom had them the balls on
them they did they did I would just rip
the ball off and cut the ball off damn
dude I had the ones that were really
long so I had to pull it all the way
down and like double four yeah you have
a double fold a sock dude roll down you
could like tuck it down over like you
know and then then I would have to yeah
you did the reverse turtleneck over
there exactly yeah and I circumcised and
then you pulled it back damn dude
you're jammed up you can't be going like
you got a nice pair of [ __ ] Old Navy
cargo shorts on you know 12 years old
you can't go out with them and the worst
part was when you went over somebody's
house and like yeah we take our shoes
off of that house and then it just like
on yeah
look at the Wicked Witch of the way
it looks like a can with a snake in it
just flying out everywhere I have to go
I have to go ankle uh or no what are
they called no shows no shows I have to
go there dude I look so bit my legs are
so bad I look but when I wear socks that
come up a little bit so you don't get
all the cut in of the ankle which there
isn't much dude I look hard I look like
I have two left feet
yeah good movie
that's my left foot you idiots
yeah it was in Philly I look like I have
two two sets of thighs when I wear a
sock dude it's bad Jesus it's real bad
that is a horrific image in my head I'm
going all ankles yeah I mean you gotta
you gotta show them off but there's
certain shoes we have to show socks like
[ __ ] otherwise if you don't it looks
like it doesn't look good you gotta have
a good combination yeah yeah like give
me an example Air Maxes yeah you got to
show some socks the Iversons if you had
those you wouldn't know sure you look
like an [ __ ] wait why it's just
linear it just yeah just whatever line
it creates on the eye it's strange like
does that look bad look at my shoe I'm
gonna say yeah
yeah it looks horrible let me see yeah
you're you you got a show yes you're
only showing in a portion of it yeah
half show half no show you're all over
the map you gotta [ __ ] or get off the
pot
if you take your shirt off you look like
you just came in off the street without
them [ __ ] [ __ ] so I'm going I'm going
pure for compression socks from here
right now above my knee dude that's a
good look keep my circulation going I
like pantyhose I don't hate it I'm not
gonna lie you know what was big back in
the day if you I think we might have
talked about this you could steal like
if you went to like a to try shoes on it
would give you like the uh [ __ ] yeah
they're the coolest guy in school
they've been watching guys take off
their shoes and having pants
so stupid it's real [ __ ] bad they're
like what is wrong with your feet about
the rubble bang what the [ __ ] could you
look like an idiot you look so defeat
about a rama you'd bust their balls back
to the Stone Age oh man all right this
one's from Jordan uh uh is it garbage if
your dad uses the same paper plate for a
few days even if it has stains on it
is that my dad
[ __ ] that's bad I feel I've done I've
reused a paper plate
not for days though
for a day not a day definitely two meals
man it's more summer my my question is
is this like one of them like I didn't
have like pasta is this a chinette plate
is this one of the plastic ones like no
like the really thick paper plates
almost like yeah yeah
I'm not using like the real disposal not
like the real just the all-white one I'm
talking about like if you've got a slice
on [ __ ] like no pizza shops no no
that's crazy that's like a coffee I
bring those home
but we're washing them all my mom has a
set of those they're plastic
the plastic plates oh man yeah we also
have the plastic silver where you kind
of can't tell if it's metal or not
because it's got a chrome finish on it
we rocked those for a couple of Parts my
mom used to make us wash those things we
would save them 100 dude we had a like a
tackle box full of [ __ ] Cutlery it
was [ __ ] wild right next time
Jesus that's [ __ ] nuts companies
coming over
yeah
it was a dwarf tackle box
uh this one's from Babyface uh ever
grocery shop at TJ Maxx or Home Goods
yes what a TGM ACCESS food that's like
not it's not they don't have protein of
candy no they have like they have you
can get like a box of it's rare it's not
there's not a cereal aisle but there'll
be a box of whatever not so much anymore
there's that Target in Center City now
it's literally all groceries there's
like two things of t-shirts it sucks
yeah it [ __ ] sucks but back in the
day there was a couple plays remember
Clover shout out to Chloe that's a good
lunch dude oh dude the food court at
Clover oh my God
awesome they had the lineup uh at our
like snack bar at our the Clover near us
they had a lineup of different
jawbreakers and they got bigger and
bigger and bigger yeah the one was like
the size of a softball yeah it was like
four grand to get it I mean it was
really about the icy that's all
and the soft pretzel was fantastic yeah
I remember the the one on Street Road
went from Clover to Value City and I was
devastated
they took out the food took it all out
when you would walk into a department
store like that as a kid say it's a a
Wednesday night you're out of school
you've already eaten dinner you're tired
it's hot in there it's like the winter
and you're going through the clothes and
you can't see you look up ahead and you
see that spinning bear with that big icy
stick it's so sick I'm thirsty as [ __ ]
now it's like an oasis
that's the only thing to come back I
still see them and think the same thing
I always I never want them anymore it's
just the fact that I haven't had one in
a long time I never think about getting
a Slurpee or an icy anytime until I see
the [ __ ] machine yeah until I see
you're not at home
I've moved on from Cherry Coke with a
lot of ice I go icy at the movies yeah
really I like it and they got all these
[ __ ] weird ass flavors now that are
like pina colada nice I stick stay up
the middle sometimes I'll mix the cherry
and the coke together or I'll go blue
raspberry like a gentleman you got a
good dude a blue rat I remember when
they rolled that out I wasn't available
everywhere so if you found a place that
had blue wraps you're like I gotta
[ __ ] get you can't pass it the first
thing that I remember when blue
raspberry I think I remember when it
when the flavor was actually came out
the first people to have it were Blow
Pops
no it was Blow Pop okay
yeah yeah in that time frame but they
came around the same time they had they
had a different wrapper the Raz did dude
it was really cool to have a blue tongue
you found one of those it was [ __ ]
wild oh yeah dude you were in a
different tax bracket for a little bit
I'll tell you what tell me [ __ ] baby
raspberry
um all right let's do one more here gang
um with the boys uh this is from cold
shawl uh never had a question read
before have you ever had a birthday
party at a hotel
in any sense
I did that in the like my early 20s
you'd be like let's go go get a room
like you would it was bad
next to the Tropicana in Atlantic City
oh that's nice I mean in the room or
like you rented one of the convention
things downstairs
we got a bathtub full of ice you put the
[ __ ] drinks in there I mean we would
we would go out to a bar or whatever but
I mean the main thing oh yeah the best
we'd order a couple Domino's five five
deals eat them before we go out and when
you come back and in the morning I had a
kids I had like my 10th birthday party
at a shitty hotel your 10th birthday
yeah I was a kid in the hotel room no it
just it was wet my dad's like there's a
pool and we went and we swam I swear to
God it was the [ __ ] I remember like
the parents dropping off my friends
they're like here was it at home or down
the shore uh it was down the shore it
was like one of like the Cadillac motels
man I was like I know the guy I was like
no you don't that's bad and we just went
in and we just we were restricted to
pool
no
we didn't stay there we lived like five
minutes away we would go so you weren't
so nobody was allowed to be there no
but my dad knew a guy I still don't know
who it was but the kids swim just like
the kids I think listen I need this I
know what he said he knew a guy I'm
pretty sure he's one of his buddies this
worked there or something no he did work
on it and was like yo no one's watching
to pull my dad's like let's go
that [ __ ] was expensive back in the day
yeah yeah oh yeah yeah we wouldn't
really go that was a big day water park
day wow one a year yeah he'll still do
now
do we used to do the Thunderbird when it
was too hot
it was the bartender there my Aunt Bobby
she probably man Bobby she probably gave
me [ __ ] chicken she's as little
Italian she weren't there for years a
hotel yeah with a pool that's so funny
you could pay like
probably was probably like five bucks or
seven bucks for the day and there's like
a bridge in it and you would swim Oh I
thought I was in the Galapagos Islands I
was [ __ ] in there but it's so funny
we used to go to like Charlie Darwin
yeah
that was great well we gotta wrap it up
gang boys we love you thank you to such
a degree we [ __ ] love you this was so
much fun this is the real garbage right
here yeah this conversation if I don't
get merch I'm gonna [ __ ] kill someone
I swear to God I said that I was like
what the [ __ ] out my mom was like how
don't I get a shirt I was like you
should
she gets half off
she get to the cost what do you want
from me
you [ __ ] the podcast fellas do yourself
a favorite gang do yourself a favor
check out the pot anything else you guys
got coming up you want the folks out
there to know no no all right
that's what I'm talking about check out
your socials you guys got a choice
stuff follow the boys
Kevin what do you got for it uh check
out our live shows we're all over the
road uh patreon the whole nine yards we
love yous gang come out and see us we
love you and we'll see you next week
peace